The solutions are negative 2 plus 3 root 2, and negative 2 minus 3 root 2.
Great thinking if you found those two answers. We start by taking the square
root of both sides of our equation. The square root of the quantity x plus 2
squared is just x plus 2. And when we take the square root of 18, we pick up
the negative root. So we have plus or minus the square root of 18. Next we
isolate x, or get it alone by subtracting 2 from both sides. We don't have
light terms here, so we have x equal to negative 2 plus or minus the root of
18. We simplify our square root of 18 by breaking into 9 times 2 and take the
square root of 9 to get our final answer. And do keep in mind there's really
two answers here: we have negative 2 plus 3 root 2 and negative 2 minus 3 root
2. Both of these values will check if we plug them into our original equation.